all right it's time for our top photos
some of them making news today number
three Amsterdam is working with a Dutch
robot company called MX 3d and
engineering software company Autodesk to
create a 3d printed bridge over a canal
there
city officials have not said where the
bridge will be but it's likely going to
be about 24 feet in length MX 3d
describes the process as drawing in
midair the process could make bridge
building safer faster and cheaper it's
expected to take two months to complete
and should be in place by 2017 can you
walk on it
Vani sometimes we look at a at a photo
and I just think the world is amazing
that's amazing I presume you can walk on
I mean that yeah I mean generally the
idea of a bridge and Amsterdam is that
it allows you to walk over the canal
that's definitional for a bridge that it
is walkable art I'm going to go behind
you guys pink gelatinous creature was
just discovered and it's still unnamed
about his founder is Stephanie Bush at
the Monterey Bay Aquarium Research
Institute has a few ideas for
classifying and naming him she's
thinking a pistol Oh
mr. tooth is mr. tooth is because he's
just so cute this adorable creature
lives and that's of the sea around 1470
six feet below the surface and as a tiny
body of only seven inches in diameter
I think Droid bird from Futurama first
rule of TNA's is you know put on
pictures of cute dogs and people will
watch this is the surveillance version
yeah this is this is this is charismatic
microphone instead of charismatic
megafauna but basically that's that's
that's how you save the world as you
show them pictures of the amazing
beautiful things that are in it I think
it's only a matter of time before that
is a mascot somewhere in the you Cal
system it's the number one Utah Valley
University is taking its texting
problems seriously the university has
divided a campus staircase into three
lanes walk run and
texts all in an effort to stop traffic
jams caused by slow-moving texting
students the university seems to have
made one mistake
there's no lane to come down the stairs
so can we get that in New York on the
sidewalks
I you know but maybe there should be a
meander Lane yeah I find that only in
Manhattan when I am in Manhattan in this
borough I get really tense and I get
stand meanders mirror is on the ground
right